imagine for a moment that you were given
the opportunity to become the most
powerful person in your country to get
there all you needed to do was betray
the very man who made you who you are
would you demure would you step back and
say thanks but no thanks so would you
grab that opportunity with both hands
well nearly half a century ago one man
in Chile made the decision to betray
everything for his own glory and his
name was August Oh Pinochet the eldest
son of middle-class Catholics Pinochet
spent the first fifty-eight years of his
life wallowing in obscurity only to
suddenly rise to infamy the driving
force of the 1973 coup that deposed
Chile's democratically elected president
Pinochet oversaw a reign of terror
almost unmatched on the continent yet he
was also a leader who counted icons like
Margaret Thatcher among his closest
friends so join us today as we delve
into the murky life of the man who
boosted Chile's economy even as he
eviscerated its soul in the lives of
evil men there are often telling details
from their early years that show us the
monsters that they will become the
serial killer who tortures animals the
future dictator who delights in
suffering in the early life of August II
Pinochet however there was nothing
nothing to suggest this young boy would
one day drown his nation in a sea of
blood born on November the 25th 1915 in
Chile's great port of Valparaiso baby
orchestra came from a solidly middle
class background his father August a
senior was a local customs official
descended from French settlers while his
mother Avelina was deeply religious
speaking of Evelina the child Pinochet
was something of a muddy eye when most
of the family moved out to the
countryside leaving Avelina
in Valparaiso Pinochet demanded to stay
with her still it's not like this
familial separation constituted hardship
Pinochet's early life it was remarkably
privileged he was even enrolled in the
sackler dos corazones private school
then one of Chile's most elite
institutions not that this stops other
boys
from picking on him though as a teenager
the boy was by his own admission
woefully weak he had a loud braying
laugh that and in the nicknamed donkey
he was also a pretty terrible students
one of the only things teenage Pinochet
was really good at was art netting
himself school prizes for his paintings
but if Pinochet ever seriously flirted
with being an artist the dream it did
not last long by the time he graduated
the boy had decided he was going to
become a soldier this was easier said
than done though Pinochet's father gusta
senior was determined that his oldest
son become a doctor but Pinochet had an
act of his sleeve Avelina doted on her
eldest son as intensely as Pinochet
revered her when the boy said he wanted
to be a soldier Avelina made damn sure a
soldier was what he became it was a
rocky road the military actually
rejected his application twice but
finally in 1933 the boy and his mother's
persistence it paid off Pinochet was
accepted to the war Academy in Santiago
the remarkable thing about penis chase
time there is just how unremarkable it
was by the time penis I graduated with a
commission in the infantry World War two
it was already looming but since Chile
decided to sit the war out only
symbolically declaring war on Nazi
Germany during the endgame Pinochet
spent his best fighting years kicking
his heels in Santiago still even way
down south in Chile world war ii it had
a potent effect the role of the USSR in
fascism's defeat galvanized communist
parties in latin america governments
responded by cracking down on them
sometimes using extreme measures by 1948
the Chilean governments was keeping
communists in internment camps
it was while they were seeing one of
these camps that Pinochet had his first
run-in with the doctor that year an
upstart socialist senator decided to
make a personal inspection of the
internment camps to see if the
Communists were being treated well when
he arrived at Pinochet s camp the man
who'd once been known as the donkey
threatened to shoot the Senate at that
Sellars his name was dr. Salvador IND
neither the doctor nor the donkey knew
it yet but their fates they were already
inextricably linked
[Music]
the story of acoustic Pinochet isn't the
story of one life so much as it is the
story of two the life of Pinochet
himself and the life of dr. Salvador
Allende born on June the 26th 1908 the
doctor's early life was eerily similar
to the donkeys like Pinochet and a was
likely born in the Chilean port of
Valparaiso even though we've seen at
least one sauce claim that he was really
born in the capital Santiago what is
certainly true is that i NZ also came
from a large middle class family with a
devoutly religious matriarch like
Pinochet and his father wanted him to
become a doctor but while Pinochet is
formative experiences would be shaped by
the military IM days they came from a
rather different direction Kwan De
Marchi is one of those figures who
exists on the sidelines of history yet
still manages to exert an outsized pull
on events an Italian immigrant cobbler
De Marchi
lived on the same street as the iron
base but he had another identity that he
liked to keep secrets De Marchi was a
committed an accursed at some point
anion days childhood the boy and the
Italian cobbler they became friends
tamaki wound up teaching the teenager
about class oppression workers rights in
the failings of capitalism although I
indeed never fell for Anna Keyes chances
under de Marquis way he became a
committed socialist it was i under in
1933 co-founded Chile's first Socialist
Party as a nd who in 1945 became one of
its first elected senators it was while
in office but it his first run-in with
Pinochet do you remember in that camp
when Pinochet threatened to shoot him
not that the doctor dwells much on that
encounter he was too busy running for
presidents in Chile's 1952 election I
and they finished an impressive dead
last
he was even temporarily booted out of
his own party for having such an abysmal
campaign but you can't keep a good
socialist down and in 1958 a and they
ran again this time though he almost won
the results it was painfully close the
Conservative candidate squeaked home
with a mere 33,000 more votes than a end
day and his team came away convinced
that next time they would absolutely win
unfortunately they they had been counted
on Fidel Castro on January the first 90
59 Fidel Castro overthrew Cuba's
government and installed a communist
dictatorship suddenly the whole of Latin
America was in the grip of a Red Scare
and trying to win elections as a
socialist was like trying to win mr.
universe when you'd look like well get
the idea I am days third presidential
run in 1964 it was a failure
the doctors public admiration of Castro
it left him a very distant second and
really that should have been the end of
it I mean you lost three elections dude
get the message but and they he didn't
get that message like Sisyphus marching
his boulder up the hill and I entered
the 1970 election determined to win
against all odds he totally did in 1970
Chile's economy was struggling there was
widespread discontent a hunger for
change to top it all off the right-wing
parties they split the vote leaving the
way open for a left-wing challenger the
result was I end a winning 36 point six
percent of the vote
a tiny mandate but more than anyone else
the shocked victory said alarm bells
ringing across the Americas in
Washington DC the Nixon administration
demanded that the CIA stopped this
upstart Marxist from taking the
presidency instead they handed iron day
the keys to the Chilean White House on
October the 25th 1970 a bunch of CIA
backed right-wing paramilitaries tried
to kidnap they Pro ironed a Chilean
general likely to clear the way for a
coup but they bungled the operation
killing the general and rallying the
Chilean public the Shannon
establishments and even the Chilean
military to a end a side suddenly the
Chilean Congress's attempts to block a
and is inauguration they were dead in
the water
on November the 5th 1970 dr. Salvador
Allende was sworn in as Chile's
president's the first democratically
elected Marxist head of state in Latin
American history barely was the
inauguration ceremony over than the CIA
began plotting do you make sure he was
also the last
[Music]
all right so we're up to 1970 now a full
22 years since we last saw Pinochet
guarding an internment camp and
threatening to shoot senators that is a
heck of a long time so well what's the
old donkey bin Nazi for all of these
years well the answer is really nothing
we can't stress enough how the most
intriguing part of Pinochet's life is
utterly how destined for obscurity he
seemed to be in 1970 he was a 55 year
old career army man whose only
contribution to world history had been
once threatening to shoot the future
presidents of Chile
the one thing that point daughter's
future notoriety was how in 1971 he was
placed in charge of the Santiago Army
Garrison you know the ideal place there
if you ever wanted to send an army
marching on the Chilean capital not the
Pinochet currently had any reason to do
so nor would he have ever had to if it
was not for the third key player in our
game and that's the CIA up in Washington
DC the Nixon White House was tearing its
hair out at i-n days election the CIA
was ordered to make the Chilean economy
scream American money flowed into right
wing Chilean propaganda into sabotage
attempts into aborted coos to be fair
and a was a scary prospect for the US
and Chilean Elise with barely a third of
the vote he was nationalizing everything
in sight still every move I under made
was in line with the Chilean
Constitution a socialist he may have
been a burgeoning tyrant he was not and
these do keep that in mind as his tragic
and bloody story plays out by 1972 I and
these governments it was widely
unpopular in an attempt to shore up
support the socialist president invited
military men into his cabinet among them
was Carlos perhaps the leading
constitutionalist in the chilean army
Pratt's wasn't happy with a NZ but he
was even less happy with the idea that
the army should remove him from power so
as long as Pratt's was running the army
there was no chance of a coup in Chile
we know this because on June the 29th
1973 a bunch of disaffected officers
tried to stage one known as the tanker
Tazo because most of those involved
attacked the president's residence La
Moneda in
the coup was a monumental failure nobody
flocked to the plotters banner when
Pinochet got wins he made sure his
garrison came out on IND side that
actually footage from this era that
appeared in the documentary the Battle
of Chile of Salvador Allende striding
down the streets of Santiago in the
cooze immediate aftermath of Augusto
Pinochet loyally at his side it was this
very moment that convinced Carlos Prats
that Pinochet was on the
constitutionalist side so when Prats
resigned a month later he made sure
Pinochet replaced him and so it was that
on August the 22nd 1973 Augusto Pinochet
became head of the Chilean Armed Forces
when michelin's heard about this they
were kind of like really that dude even
Pinochet wife thought that he was joking
but it was no joke perhaps have just
promoted the most unremarkable man in
Chile to a position of remarkable power
it was a decision that would soon
destroy him
many years later long after Salvador and
it was dared Pinochet would boast that
had been plotting a coup against the
Socialists for more than a year but
other sources paint a picture not of a
cunning man waiting for his chance but a
nobody who accidentally wound up heading
a conspiracy on September the 8th
Chile's other generals they confronted
Pinochet
while no record exists off the
conversation it seems that basically
they said look we're gonna overthrow a
and a and you too
if you stand in our way now are you in
or are you out turns out Pinochet was
way in on September the 11th 1973 the
residents of Santiago awoke to the
earth-shaking thud of explosions across
the capital military fighter jets were
bombing laminator each pass course new
plumes of smoke to spiral up towards the
clear blue sky imagine watching on the
TV as the White House's consumed by
flames knowing those burning is her
American soldiers that's what millions
of Chileans felt on that fateful morning
in a great historical irony and is first
reaction as the coup got underway it was
to matter I wonder what they've done
with poor Pinochet he had no way of
knowing that the last army man he
thought was loyal to him was directing
the bombs they were raining down around
him and his last stand today is
legendary arms with a Kalashnikov given
to him by Fidel Castro he and his
entourage managed to hold off the
Chilean army for hours but there was
only one way this could ever end as
soldiers swarmed the flaming ruins of
laminator dr. Salvador and a shot
himself through the head he was 65 years
old out on the streets of Santiago
leftists protesters artists and
intellectuals we're all being rounded up
and marched to the internment camps that
were springing up across the city most
notoriously this included the National
Stadium where dissidents were tortured
in locker rooms before being dragged out
onto the pitch and shot through the head
at the same time announcements were
going out that Chile was now under
control of a four-man military hunter
headed by General Pinochet as the shock
waves of the coop spread out the old
constitutional as general Carlos Pratt's
zipped out of Santiago for exile in
Argentina yet the man who had made
Pinochet wouldn't be able to outrun
erstwhile friends for very long on
September the 30th 1974 a car bomb
killed Pratt's and his wife in Buenos
Aires it's thought the Pinochet himself
ordered the assassination back in
Santiago the Hunter instituted a reign
of repression political parties there
were banned censorship put in place all
leftist media was shut down around
80,000 people were arrested another
200,000 were forced into exile not that
the Hansa itself lost very long go on
dream the 27th 1974 just ten months
after the coup Pinochet used his clout
within the army to force the other
hunter leaders to step aside in their
place here himself elevated to supreme
chief of the nation the long tradition
of democratic rule in Chile
it was nowt an end for next 16 years the
donkey would rule his nation as its
undisputed king from the get-go the
regime of Augusto Pinochet it marked
itself out for its sheer brutality one
of Pinochet first acts was to order a
mop-up operation against leftists who
still remained in Chile known as the
caravan of death this unit travelled the
vast length of Chile's deserts and
wastelands flying into small towns and
executing anyone who opposed military
rule all told 97 Chileans were murdered
by the caravan in some cases they were
flown far out over the Pacific in
helicopters and simply held to their
fates meanwhile those who'd been
arrested in the aftermath of the coup
were funneled into concentration camps
that's in the dry Atacama Desert old
saltpeter works were turned into centers
where leftists will work to death or
executed by being blown up with dynamite
similar camps appeared in the frozen
wastes of Patagonia but the worst of the
new regimes torture centers they were
right in the capital the Villa Grimaldi
was once a grand old colonial house now
it became a monument to mankind's worst
impulses at the still awful but normal
end of the scale prisoners there were
suffocated to the point of death and
then released at the nastier ends the
teenage daughters of regime critics were
kidnapped and used as practice for
soldiers learning the ropes of
electroshock torture but it doesn't end
there at the most deranged of all female
prisoners were forced to have
intercourse with animals while their
guards
watched and laughed it was the Grand
Guignol of horror but it wasn't just
confined to Chile in November of 1975
Pinochet secret police the DIA made
contacts with the dictatorships of
Brazil Paraguay and Uruguay later
including Argentina after the March 1976
military coup together they came up with
something called Operation Condor its
goal was to assassinate every single
leftist on the continent the idea was
that the döner would pass information on
Chilean dissidents to the other Condor
nations and vice versa they would then
disappear one another's enemies for the
60,000 people killed by Condor that
meant being dropped into deep lakes or
rivers or shot and buried in remote mass
graves that no one would ever find
sometimes though it meant a more
dramatic end on September the 21st 1976
Salvador Allende's former Foreign
Minister Orlando l'Italia got into his
car in Washington DC where he'd been
living in exile since the coup with him
was a 25 year old US citizen Ronnie
Moffett at 9:30 a.m.
a bomb concealed in the car exploded
killing both occupants even the capital
of the United States it wasn't safe from
Pinochet's reach yet this terror it only
strengthened Pinochet's grip on power as
the 1980s dawned the Chilean sirens
rammed through a new constitution giving
himself eight year times as presidents
come 1988 there would be a yes or no
referendum on whether Pinochet could
keep power until then he would be the
one-man ruler of Chile Chile's
dictatorship well it was here to stay
[Music]
by this point you might be wondering why
such a perverse regime wasn't an
international pariah the reasons can be
summed up in a single phrase and that's
the miracle of Chile that was the name
given by the free-market economist
Milton Friedman to what happens in Chile
after Pinochet seized power and the
successive governments Chile's economy
had been badly struggling during i-n
days years in office things had only
gotten worse although it's debatable
whether that was due to his left-wing
policies or due to the CIA constantly
trying to instigate coup when Pinochet
took over he decided to try a new route
one mapped out by the Chicago boys the
Chicago boys were Native Chileans who'd
studied in Chicago under Friedman
suddenly elevated by the regime to keep
positions they were tasked with
transforming the economy and transform
it they did in the second half of the
1970s Chile became a laboratory for
perhaps the most extreme free-market
economic policies in history everything
that wasn't bolted down was privatized
everything was opened up to the market
and businesses were given unfettered
access to all parts of Chilean life the
results was a wild roller coaster ride
that saw both the highest inflation rate
in Chile's history and one of the worst
one-year recessions on record but by the
time 1988 arrived the wild ride was over
Chile's economy was the most stable in
Latin America Chile was rich
Pinochet his supporters still point to
this as his signature achievements it
certainly won the regime friends with
Margaret Thatcher openly talking about
her admiration of Pinochet
but even here we should sound a note of
caution Chile today is successful but it
also has one of the highest levels of
inequality in the world the Chicago boys
they may have made Chile rich but they
did so while eviscerating the poorest in
society come 1988 Pinochet he was riding
high the economy was doing great all his
enemies were dead and he was secured in
power so when it came time to hold their
referendum that we mentioned earlier the
one about keeping Pinochet as dictator
Pinochet went ahead and he held it
despite all the abuses he thought that
he really was popular how could the hero
who delivered Chile from socialism
possibly lose but a Pinochet thought he
was Chile's hero Chile's electorate was
about to prove they still saw him as a
donkey for October the 5th 1988 the
plebiscite returned its shock results
the Pro Pinochet side had scraped a mere
44% of the vote the anti Pinochet side
had won by 12 points the next day an
outraged Pinochet called his generals to
his offices and declared that he would
never stand down that the vote was a fix
that it was all a mistake but the
generals they knew something that the
old donkey didn't they knew that the US
was already piling on the pressure that
Pinochet would have to honor the results
or it'd be facing international
consequences one by one they refused to
back Pinochet isolated the dictator had
no choice but to publicly announce that
he would step down in the next year 1989
the first presidential election since
1970 was held in Chile the center-left
candidate Patricio Aylwin romps home
with 55% of the vote
suddenly the age of oppression it was
over by now and was inaugurated on March
the 11th 1990 democracy finally returned
to Chile of course Pinochet didn't just
return to civilian life he remained head
of the Armed Forces and his later gifted
not just the post of senator for life
but immunity from prosecution but if the
donkey thought that he would have an
easy retirement well he had another
thing coming
[Music]
on October the 17th 1998 orgastic
Pinochet was visiting London from -
surgery on his back ever since had
stepped down as Chile's leader eight
long years ago the former dictator had
grown fond of the British capital
thanks to Chile's clandestine help to
Britain during the Falklands War he
thought the British had grown fond of
him too but the British well they were
about to give him a rather rude
awakening that day as the 83 year old
Pinochet lay in hospital he was arrested
by officers from London's Met Police
seven days earlier a Spanish judge known
as Balthazar Garzon had issued an
international arrest warrant for
Pinochet under Spanish law serious
crimes against Spanish citizens can be
charged in Spanish courts in that er
what jurisdiction they are committed in
several Spanish citizens had been
abducted and tortured in Chile during
the regime and now was payback time the
arrest was like a lightning bolt to the
international community suddenly the
eyes of Pinochet as many victims were
all trained on London we wish that we
could now wrap this video up by saying
that Pinochet was extradited to Madrid
where the judge found him guilty and he
was sentenced to a bazillion years in
prison but sadly that's not what
happened although British Parliament
ruled international immunity did not
apply in cases of torture the
establishment still closed ranks to
protect a foreign leader on the
conservative side Margaret Thatcher made
an impassioned plea for Pinochet to be
freed on the Labor Party side
the Home Secretary Jack Straw declared
Pinochet was too ill to stand trial on
March 3rd 2000 Pinochet was wheeled onto
a plane from London to Chile looking
like he was at death's door when he
touched down in Santiago the dictator
triumphant police stood up from his
wheelchair and smugly waved at his
supporters as is so often the case with
history the monster had escaped
unscathed
however there's still a postscript to
this story while the Spanish warrant
never went anywhere at home in Chile
lawmakers were starting to reassess the
idea of lifetime immunity in 2004 a
State Commission on the crimes of the
dictatorship dropped a shocking report
that revealed that over 35,000 people
had been tortured by the regime and over
3,000 had been murdered
that same year Chilean lawmakers lifted
Pinochet immunity over the caravan of
death
and the car bomb assassination of the
constitutionalist general carlos perhaps
one year later in 2005 Pinochet was
placed under house arrest it was only
days after his 90th birthday
over the next year more and more
allegations came to light evidence of
colossal levels of embezzlement was
presented in 2006 Pinochet was formally
charged with kidnapping torture and
murder sadly though the stubborn old
donkey once again escaped justice on
December the 10th 2006 Pinochet died of
a heart attack in his home in Santiago
just days earlier had been told that he
was fit to stand trial
today the Chilean state has began to
slowly account for the crimes committed
during Pinochet s-- tenure over 40
thousand living victims have been
identified and provided with
compensation around 1300 former soldiers
and officers have been tried for crimes
against humanity Chile may still be
haunted by the shadow of Augusto
Pinochet but at least history is now
able to judge him for the monster that
he was he may have escaped justice in
his lifetime the Pinochet crimes will
still go down in history so I really
hope you found that video interesting if
you did why not give us a thumbs up
below and subscribe and hit that
notification bell all of that good stuff
if you're looking for more from this
chair I'm going to link to some old
videos on the screen right now so check
those out if you want to and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]